Sir Michael you've reiterated yesterday
that also the new defense policy of the
UK will put NATO at its core how much
does talk about NATO talk about how much
it still is a stable structure damage
that aligns itself well well the
Alliance needs to stick together now
they'll answer is being tested it's
being tested by Russia it's been tested
by terrorism in the Middle East there's
never been a time when Europe and NATO
really need to stick together and
Britain is going to be part of that when
leading the very high readiness task
force the response unit of NATO all this
year we're deploying troops to Estonia
we're deploying RAF aircraft to Romania
for Southern Air Policing we will
continue to lead in NATO to help bring
that reassurance that the Alliance needs
there was a lot of talk here to
strengthen alliances to avoid a fall
back to Spears of influence now you're
about to leave a very strong Alliance at
the European Union how much are you
becoming a sphere of influence for the
United States well we're leaving a the
political European Union but we're not
leaving the continent Europe remains our
continent and we're going to go on
contributing to the security of that
continent we also have this
transatlantic relationship our oldest
and strongest ally is with the over the
United States it's a very strong defense
relationship so we see that benefiting
both that we see that benefiting the
United States where we will be a bridge
between Europe and the United States but
it also benefits the Alliance as a whole
that Britain is able to link with the
United States in that way now Britain
has always been skeptical of EU
ambitions to build up its own force you
are hinging your defense even more on
NATO even more on your us part in the
future how's that going to work or
defenses for NATO not the European Union
and we're not alone in there trying to
encourage the European Union to avoid
duplicating what is being done in NATO
NATO has to be our primary defense and
at the last NATO summit we agreed that
the European Union and NATO need to work
more closely together
to avoid duplication so we have with
other members of the European Union we
have been resisting calls for a European
headquarters or a European army we don't
need that we have NATO we need to make
NATO work properly for everybody you
will no doubt they go ahead without you
on that though will you still be a
stakeholder in that process at all well
it's not just Britain that's been
pointing to the need not to set up new
unnecessary structures many of the other
when we discussed this in Bratislava in
September many other European countries
joined with us saying look we already
have NATO we don't need a ueu army we
don't need an EU headquarters they have
different roles Europe has the political
role it can impose sanctions for example
on on on Putin it has the diplomatic
clout but it is NATO that is the
military power and it's very important
that we don't have two competing
organizations so Michael thank you very
much thanks